here's an incredible trick to multiply  numbers label your fingers 6 to 10 from  thumb to pinky finger on each hand to do  seven times eight touch the fingers of  seven and eight then count the touching  fingers and the ones below this is five  fingers which makes for 50 in the answer  then we have three on one hand  multiplied by two on the other hand  which makes for six so seven times eight  is equal to fifty-six  let's do another example of six times  nine we touch the fingers of six and  nine and we count the touching fingers  and the ones below which is equal to  five so we have fifty in the answer we  then have four multiplied by one which  is equal to four so six times nine is  equal to fifty-four now if you wanted to  do six times seven you count the  touching fingers and the ones below  which is equal to three so we have  Thirty in the answer then we have four  multiplied by three which is equal to  twelve so thirty plus twelve is equal to  42 and that's the answer amazing